Kurzpass. Atlanta United hat die Major League Soccer gewonnen und das erst im der zweiten Saison Teilnahme. Was sagt das über die Major League Soccer aus? Diese Frage und viele andere beantwortet uns Jürgen Kalwa aus New York. Jürgen, schön dich mal wieder mit dabei zu haben.
Hey, guten Tag oder guten Morgen. Ich hier ist ja noch, ich glaube gerade erst die Sonne aufgegangen.
Ja, und das ist ja im Podcastland sowieso alles relativ. Deswegen, wie könnte es besser passen, als dass bei uns beiden schon die Uhrzeiten so unterschiedlich sind? Sehr schön dich mal wieder mit dabei zu haben. Ich kenne so einige da draußen, die jetzt Fanboy und Fangirl-artig kreischen werden, als sie den Namen von dir gehört haben. Doch, doch, ich bin mir da schon ziemlich sicher. Der Mann mit der Stimme aus Karamell, ich glaube so habe ich dich das letzte Mal genannt, im Rasen. Das lassen wir so stehen. Wir wollen über die Major League Soccer sprechen im Rahmen dieses 106. Kurzpasses. Und ich habe es ja schon im Intro gesagt, Jürgen. Atlanta United FC hat jetzt das Finale gewonnen. Mit dabei waren auch zwei deutsche Spieler, Kevin Kratz und Julian Gressel. Allein deshalb hat man auch hier in Deutschland ein bisschen was davon mitbekommen. Aber die Frage, die sich für mich als keinen Intimus der Major League Soccer stellt, was sagt denn das über eine Liga aus, wenn man im zweiten Jahr, in der zweiten Teilnahme schon Meister werden kann? Wie war das überhaupt möglich?
Also was man am Anfang immer erwähnen sollte, ist, dass es wirklich fast doppelt schwierig ist, dieser Liga aus den Startlöchern heraus so gut abzuschneiden. Weil man kann sich nicht einfach eine Mannschaft zusammenkaufen. Das System, aufgrund dessen das eben abgebremst ist, mit solchen Stichworten wie salary cap belegt oder auch draft.
Also eine Gehaltsobergrenze.
Ja, und draft, also dieses System, dass man in einen Topf greift, in den alle greifen können. Und dann auch dieses, auch aus den anderen Ligen abgekupferte System von Spielertausch im Sinne von, wenn ich bei einem anderen Club mir etwas mehr rausschneiden möchte, dann muss ich auch einen Gegenwert zurückgeben. Das heißt, ich kann nicht wirklich unterm Strich einfach plus produzieren. Ich muss immer auch schauen, wie wäge ich ab. Das heißt, das hat einen eigenen Reiz, ist aber eben in diesen über 20 Jahren der Liga von vielen Leuten, die glaubten, sie verstehen das und können das gut managen, nicht besonders gelungen. Also ich glaube mal, das erste Beispiel aus deutscher Sicht war, wie holt man jemanden wie Lothar Matthäus in die Liga und hofft, dass das dann Auswirkungen hat. Das ist so aus der Abteilung Altstar, der noch was drauf hat, der noch einen Ball schieben kann und so. Die Backcamp-Phase war so, dass man auch merkte, naja, dann haben sie halt einen prominenten Spieler, der auch das Publikum anzieht. Aber wenn es darum geht, den Rest der Mannschaft zu managen, den man ja auch braucht, dann ging das also so gut wie gar nicht am Anfang. Es hat sehr lange gedauert, bis die überhaupt dann die Qualität erreicht haben, dass sie auch mal einen Titel gewonnen haben. Also das haben die Leute in Atlanta, glaube ich, ganz gut verstanden. Die haben von Anfang an gewusst, so einfach ist das nicht. Und vielleicht gibt es ja andere Möglichkeiten. Und wenn man sich dann anguckt, an welcher Stelle die wichtigsten Hebel umgelegt worden sind, dann würde man wahrscheinlich, so wie das die New York Times auch mal neulich mit einem langen Artikel getan hat, würde man die Entscheidung für den Chefmanager herausheben müssen. Darren Eales heißt er, ein Engländer. Der hatte Premier League Erfahrungen und der hat dann zwei Dinge getan. Erstens hat er halt einen Trainer verpflichtet, Tata, der wirklich Qualität hat und einen Blick hat und natürlich auch die sprachlichen Möglichkeiten, mit einem der Haupttalentenmärkte für diese Liga gut umzugehen und das ist Mittel- und Südamerika. Die MLS ist ja in ihrer Rolle, der lange mal auf dem Spielermarkt hat, die sich da so hin entwickelt, dass man die zweite Kategorie von Spielern kriegen kann, die es in Europa dann nicht schafft, die aus Südamerika und aus Mittelamerika kommen und da wird man wohl auch diesem Trainer ganz viel Verdienste zusprechen müssen.
Der eben Trainer von Paraguay und Argentinien war, mit Paraguay im Finale der Copa America, mit Argentinien zweimal im Finale der Copa America und liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, der Name ist euch auch daher bekannt, weil er der Nachfolger von Tito Villanova beim FC Barcelona war. Das nur kurz als Einschub zu dieser Person. Also wenn derjenige bei deinem Spieler anruft oder auf deinem Handy sein Name erscheint, dann gehst du erstmal ran, gerade als südamerikanischer oder mittelamerikanischer Fußballspieler.
Naja, und der ist jetzt auch bald wieder weg. Wir werden jetzt rausfinden können, man kann nicht alles auf den Trainer schieben, aber wir werden rausfinden, ob das ein wichtiger Faktor gewesen ist. Denn wenn er nicht mehr da ist, kann die Mannschaft auch nicht mehr so spielen, wie sie gespielt hat. Ich weiß nicht, wie stark sie sich verändern werden. Wir haben ja noch jetzt erstmal Saisonpause bis zum Frühjahr.
Wir haben ja gerade das Finale gespielt, aber warum geht er denn eigentlich? Also es war schon vor dem gespielten Finale klar, ich glaube sogar vor dem Playoffs wurde das schon bekannt. Warum verabschiedet er sich schon wieder von diesem Projekt?
Ich habe das jetzt nicht genau verfolgt. Ich gehe davon aus, dass man einfach im Laufe der Zeit hier nicht genug verdient und auch nicht genug Reputation verdienen kann. Also ein interessantes Intermezzo für jemanden, schon vor allen Dingen, wenn es gut läuft. Aber wir sind hier, trotz aller Versuche der Liga-Führung, das Ganze zu einem unglaublich tollen Ereignis hoch zu jubeln, sind wir natürlich, wenn wir das Ganze mit anderen Ligen und anderem Fußball auf der Welt vergleichen, sind wir natürlich Entwicklungsland.
Okay, gut, also es gibt auch keine genauen Gründe darüber. Er hat einfach eine Vertragsverlängerung abgelehnt, habe ich mir jetzt noch mal kurz angelesen in einer schnellen Zeit. Also wir haben den Sportdirektor und wir haben den Trainer, fehlen ja noch die Spieler. Welchen Weg ist denn da Atlanta United gegangen und unterscheidet er sich von anderen Teams?
Nö, also die haben natürlich auch, dass ein ähnliches Konzept sich erarbeitet wie die anderen auch. Also man nimmt halt dafür ein paar Leute, die gut und relativ teuer sind, wenn auch nicht ganz so teuer, wie das sich inzwischen schon entwickelt hat. Also wir haben hier mit Miguel Almiron und Ezequiel Barco, Josef Martínez, haben wir halt die teuren Spieler, die verdienen halt so zwischen einer und zweieinhalb Millionen Dollar im Jahr, wenn man alles einrechnet. Also die gehören eben zu den Ausnahmespielern an dieser Liga. Die also erlaubt, dass ein Club eben ein paar Leute sehr viel besser bezahlen kann. Weshalb man ja auch dieses Phänomen jetzt pflegt, das wir dann noch mit jemandem wie Bastian Schweinsteiger in Chicago gesehen haben, der ist ja da auch für relativ viel Geld hingeholt worden, oder Ebrahimovic nach LA Galaxy. Und dann ist das hier eine bunte Liste von Leuten, wo die Amerikaner wahrscheinlich nur einen wirklich kennen, Brad Gusan, der Torwart, der ist eben auch Nationaltorwart. Der Rest ist relativ, das internationale Fußballproletariat, das hier antritt. Zu denen dann auch Julian Gresselgaard und Kevin Kratz. Und wenn es jemanden interessiert, weil ich gerade auf die Liste schaue, erzähle ich auch noch gerne, was diese beiden Herren verdienen.
Ja, natürlich. Wenn wir das schon mal wissen, so genau, ohne die Football Leagues.
Ja, wobei wir halt in Amerika eine Transparenz haben, bei fast allen Ligen, was das Geld angeht. Und ja, Gressel, mit allem, wenn alles zusammenkommt, 111.000 Dollar im Jahr, Kratz 179.250 Dollar im Jahr. Das ist Zweitliganiveau in Deutschland.
Das ordnet das auch schon ganz gut ein. Und was für ein Fußball spielt Atlanta, beziehungsweise, kannst du uns mal so ein bisschen einfinden, was erwartet einen denn, wenn man die Major League Soccer intensiver verfolgt? Ich habe jetzt nur das Finale gesehen und Finalspiele sind ja immer ein bisschen zäh.
Von Mannschaftssport in den USA und von an den Colleges gepflegten, trainerfixierten Ideen von, wie man Mannschaftssportarten trainiert und wie man sie dann umsetzt. Da ist ganz wichtig Hurra, Begeisterung, Wille, Kampf, Ehrgeiz.
Das ist ja wirklich zweite Liga, super.
Fitness. Also hat man Spieler, die sind wirklich schnell, also schnell nicht unbedingt jetzt Weltklasse schnell, aber in der Tendenz schnell. Die können auch 90 Minuten lang laufen. Und die können auch vor allem rauf und runter laufen. Also die haben auch nicht dieses innere Problem. Es gibt ja auch den Typ von Spielern, der sagt, was soll das eigentlich? Der hängt da mal durch und schlurft mal irgendwo rum oder so, wenn der Trainer nicht genau hinguckt. Das kennen wir so nicht. Also wir haben hier diesen blauäugig Kämpfer, so diesen Nibelungen Siegfried-artigen Typ von Fußballer, der hier gepflegt wird. Inzwischen natürlich ein bisschen eingemischt, weil wir haben eben Lateinamerikaner, die sind ein bisschen anders drauf. Die können auch mit dem Ball ein bisschen besser umgehen. Aber das ist eben nicht die Luxusfassung von dem, was wir aus Südamerika kennen. Und Trainer, die also gerne den Spielern eigentlich auch was aufzwingen wollen, was ja im Prinzip nicht doof ist. Aber wenn man mit dem Arbeit muss, was man hat, wäre eigentlich der Trainer-Typ der bessere, der wie mit den 49 Zahlen beim Lotto gut umgehen kann. Und sagen kann, okay, wir spielen jetzt mit diesen Zahlen und holen uns da halt eine gute Quote. Das können nur wenige Trainer hier. Und wir müssen auch sagen, wir haben ja auch jetzt nicht unbedingt die große Trainer-Qualität. Das heißt, wir haben ja nicht die besten Trainer der Welt. So ergibt sich eben ein Bild, dass ein kampforientierter, relativ schneller Ball gespielt wird. Aber der zweite oder dritte Pass ist eigentlich eher ein Zufallsprodukt. Den Ball kontrollieren, im Spiel halten, ein Spiel dominieren, sich auch bewusst mal ganz jämmerlich zurückfallen lassen, aber trotzdem defensiv orientiert den Ball halten und den Gegner Mühe machen und so. Das sind alles Entwicklungsphasen von Fußball, die hier wenn überhaupt noch gelernt werden müssen. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob das wirklich das Publikum merkt. Denn das wäre jetzt mein letzter Seitenhieb, wenn man für ein Publikum spielt, das nun auch nicht wirklich verwöhnt ist und trotzdem irgendwie mitmacht und trotzdem begeistert ist und in die Stadien strömt, dann kriegt man natürlich auch keine kritische Resonanz.
Muss ja dann vielleicht auch gar nicht sein. Also der Erfolg, der Publikumserfolg, spricht da durchaus für das, was man da in der MLS sehen kann. Also der Zuschauerschnitt ist jetzt relativ konstant in den letzten Jahren bei ca. 22.000 Zuschauern pro Spiel. Da muss man dazusagen, in der letzten Saison wurden 391 Spiele gespielt. Es sind insgesamt 23 Teams in zwei Divisions. Und dann gibt es noch ein Playoff-System. So kommt man auf relativ viele Spiele. Und Atlanta United zum Beispiel hat über 30.000 Dauerkarten verkauft im zweiten Jahr der Liga-Zugehörigkeit und einen Schnitt von über 50.000 Zuschauern. Also die Leute strömen zuhauf in die Stadien.
Anmerkung. Wir haben im Grunde auch hier, das gibt es ja in anderen Ligen, in ähnlichen Situationen auch. Wir haben eigentlich zwei Klassen von Fan-Kultur. Wir haben die Orte, in denen wirklich eine enorme Begeisterung entstanden ist, auch relativ spät. Das ist zum Beispiel in Seattle als erstem Ort gelungen, wo man in einem großen Football-Stadion spielt. Und da kommen im Schnitt so um die 40.000 Leute. Orlando ist auch ein relativ neuer Club, hat auch einen größeren Einfluss auf die Durchschnittszahlen. Und jetzt mit Atlanta und den Zahlen, die du gerade erwähnt hast, ziehen wir den Schnitt noch weiter hoch. Das ist aber wirklich nur so punktuell. Und in der Mathematik wissen wir ja den Unterschied zwischen Schnitt und Mittel. Der Schnitt wird halt durch solche Zahlen ganz schnell nach oben gezogen. In der Mitte heißt das noch nicht alles. Also wir haben auch wirtschaftliche Probleme in einigen Orten, wobei einige werden offen behandelt, einige sind verkappt. Die Liga macht nach wie vor keinen Gewinn. Das ist ganz wichtig. Was da passiert, ist showtechnisch sehr gut. Und die Zuschauerzahlen in den Stadien, das ist eine gute Information. Das ist ja auch eine Stimmung, die man einfängt und die man auch projizieren kann.
Hat ja verfangen. Also der Moderator dieses Formats hier hat sich diese Zahlen notiert.
Ja, und das ist ja auch okay. Mit irgendwas muss man ja anfangen, mit irgendwas muss man ja auch zeigen, dass man das greift, was man da probiert. Sonst könnte man ja gleich aufhören. Also das ist jetzt keine substanzielle Kritik an dem, was da passiert. Man müsste nur, wie ich das mal von einem fränkischen Chefredakteur immer wieder gehört habe, man müsste halt Obacht geben, dass das vielleicht doch nicht die ganze Geschichte ist. Und dass das Ganze, das ganze Unternehmen, diese Liga, die ja nun allen Club-Eigentümern zusammengehört, das ist auch noch mal eine Besonderheit. Wir haben hier nicht Clubs, wir haben hier nicht mal Franchises im eigentlichen Sinne, weil die werden ja eigenständige Unternehmer, nein, diese ganze Liga gehört allen zusammen. Das heißt, auch alle Spieler sind eigentlich bei allen angestellt und nicht bei einem Einzelnen. Und der Verteilungsmechanismus, der ist nun abgekupfert von dem, wie man in anderen Sportarten, Mannschaftssportarten kommerziell sich aufstellt. Das gehen wir wahrscheinlich von einer Baustelle zu anderen. Also vielleicht zurück zu der Frage, was passiert da? Also was die Liga als Ganzes, auch am Anfang sehr heikle Phasen doch hinbekommen hat, ist diese Grundstabilität. Die Fähigkeit, weil die Saison ja schräg läuft, von Frühjahr bis zum Spätherbst, in dieser Phase auch gegen andere Sportarten, sich genug abzugrenzen. Und diese Abgrenzung, die ganz, ganz wichtig war, nach meiner Einschätzung, dass man sich eigene Stadien gebaut hat. Das hat eine Weile gedauert, aber das war auch irgendwann mal für alle, die da Verantwortung haben, klar, wir können nicht in diesen Football-Stadien spielen, die sind fast immer zu groß. Und wenn dann die NFL auch noch Saison hat, dann siehst du da die unglaublichsten Abkreidungen auf diesen Rasenflächen. Du kannst den Strafraumkommen sehen, ich glaube, den haben sie gerne in Gelb dann abgekreidet oder so. Du siehst also sofort aus wie so ein ganz armes Mäuschen, wie Aschenputtel im amerikanischen Sport. Du brauchst deine eigene Bühne, deine eigene Plattform. Und das hat man konsequent durchgesetzt. Und wenn ich jetzt hier noch einen Schlenker machen darf, also Stichwort Beckham, der ja nun gerade versucht, in Miami einen Fußball-Club auf die Beine zu stellen.
Inter Miami, ja, kommt 2020.
Die Schwierigkeiten, weshalb das so lange gedauert hat, lagen jetzt in der Verpflichtung, der muss ein Stadion bauen und diesen Plan auf die Beine stellen. Und für den finanziellen Teil gab es überhaupt keine Probleme. Der Mann hat genug Co-Investoren, die bereit sind, da mitzumachen. Das Problem war hier ein rein städtebauliches, die Erlaubnis zu bekommen, Flächen nutzen zu können, entweder Dinge abzureißen, umzupflügen oder, ja, Gelände oder Sprachlag irgendwie zu benutzen und der ist da mehrfach vor eine Wand gelaufen, weil er sich mit bestimmten Projekten da verliebt hat. In Projekte. Und so kann man manchmal eben auch drauf hinweisen, es gibt ganz andere Faktoren dafür, wie diese Liga läuft, wie diese Clubs funktionieren. Die haben nichts mit dem Sport zu tun. Die haben nicht mal was mit dem Geld zu tun, das man braucht, um das auf die Beine zu stellen. Das ist also eine ganz faszinierende Gemengelage.
Ja, absolut. Also David Beckham hat eben sein eigenes Team gegründet. Es gibt schon das Logo, noch kein Stadion. Bei Atlanta war das auch einer der Gründe, warum es erst in Anführungszeichen vor zwei Jahren dann in der MLS losging. Vorher noch in der zweiten Liga, glaube ich. Vor vier Jahren war das dann, weil man da auch auf das Football-Stadion warten musste, das fertig gebaut wurde. Für die Atlanta Falcons übrigens ist es auch der gleiche Auna. Also Arthur Blank, ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, wie er am Superbowl schon unten am Spielfeld ran stand, bei diesem legendären Comeback der New England Patriots gegen Atlanta. War das vor zwei Jahren für alle Football-Fans da draußen. Aber jetzt haben wir immer noch nicht so ganz, finde ich, die Faszination der MLS beschreiben können. Also sportlich hält sich die Relevanz immer noch im Rahmen. Ich finde, du hast das ganz gut eingeordnet. Das, was ich gesehen habe, ich habe in diesem Jahr das Finale verfolgt. Im letzten Jahr habe ich bei den Playoffs ziemlich viel mir angeguckt. Das ist so ungefähr, wie du es beschrieben hast. Es kann nicht ganz mithalten mit Europäischen Ligen und das ist dann schon ein Euphemismus. Eher so Zweitliganiveau einer Europäischen Liga. Und trotzdem ja eben diese einzelnen Standorte, von denen es ja jetzt peu a peu immer mehr als weniger gibt, an denen so eine hohe Begeisterung für diesen Sport da ist. In Beschreibungen, die den US-Sport generell behandeln, hört man immer wieder das Argument, weil der American Football neben Baseball, Amerikas liebstes Kind, im ausgeführten Sport, Basketball muss man vielleicht noch mit dazu nehmen, aber weil die da so große Probleme unter anderem mit Kopfverletzungen haben, schicken Familien ihre Kinder lieber zum Fußball, der als weniger gefährlich für die Kinder angesehen wird. Und das wird immer als ein Argument herangezogen, warum der Fußball größer werden würde in den USA. Im Frauenfußball ja schon länger und jetzt auch im Männerfußball. Ist denn das jetzt auch wieder so eine europäische Sichtweise, die sich eigentlich nicht mit dem hält, was du dann vor Ort beobachten kannst? Oder woher kommt es, dass der Fußball doch ja an Fans zu gewinnt?
Ja, ich finde, man darf das ruhig mit reinnehmen in die Betrachtung. Ich glaube, die eigentliche Frage, die sich so eine Liga dann stellen muss, wenn sie so langsam in Fahrt kommt, ist, wie man ein effektiv vorhandenes Reservoir an Interesse, das ist in den USA, was Fußball angeht, sehr groß, wie man das nutzen kann. Und das Reservoir besteht aus Millionen von Kindern, die an den Fußball herangeführt werden, die dann zum Beispiel in den Schulen, wo Sport ja anders als in Deutschland sehr stark verankert ist, die dort also in Mannschaften groß werden. Und wer dann eben da nicht Football spielt, weil das können ja nun auch nicht alle, oder wer da nicht Baseball spielt, das können eben nicht alle, der hat auch eine Chance beim Fußball. Und Fußball ist eben auch eine Sportart, die sehr viel verschiedene Typen von Athletik verarbeiten kann. Da können halt große und kleine und mittlere und manchmal auch etwas stämmige oder so. Die können alle irgendwie mitmachen und die sitzen auch nicht rum auf der Bank, die können dann alle spielen und so. Also Fußball hat erst mal von der Grundausstattung her, als das angefangen hat in Amerika vor 30, 40 Jahren, hat einen unglaublichen Boom an dieser Basis erlebt. Das Problem ist dann, was passiert auf der nächsten Ebene. Und da hat es eben, auch das ist Tradition, einen wirklich schwierigen Flaschenhals gegeben, ehe diese Profiliga auf die Beine gestellt wurde. Und das ist College-Fußball. Es ist durchaus sinnig für einen halbwegs talentierten, jungen Spieler von der Schule, der ein Stipendium haben möchte, beim Fußball zu bleiben. Und dann macht er auf der Uni, wo er ein Stipendium bekommt, seinen Abschluss und geht dann mit seinem Leben irgendwo anders hin. Er ist 22, 23 Jahre alt und es geht weiter. Also jemand wie Gressel ist ja auch am College gelandet, in Rhode Island, glaube ich. Ich habe das nochmal nachgeguckt und hat sich eben da sicherlich erst mal nicht ausgerechnet, das ist die Plattform für mein weiteres sportliches Leben, sondern das ist vielleicht einfach so eine Mischung. Ich mache da einen Abschluss und dann gucke ich mir weiter. Problem Nummer eins, College Fußball war nie ein intensiver Sport, war saisonal immer nur eine knappe Veranstaltung, ist es auch heute noch. Vom Training her habe ich vorhin schon mal beschrieben, was dafür Leute das sagen haben und wie da gespielt wird. Dazu kommt, dass man Spieler in der Altersgruppe von 18 bis 22, wo sehr viel Entwicklung vielleicht noch möglich ist, aber eigentlich dann wegsaugt von der Entwicklungsmöglichkeit Richtung Profisport. In den frühen Phasen haben sich dann eben amerikanische Talente nach Europa aufmachen können, haben sich dort ein bisschen weiterentwickeln können. Das war aber immer alles sehr selten. So, jetzt kommt diese Profi-Liga irgendwann vernünftigerweise, wird installiert, wird aber sehr besorgt installiert. Warum? Weil dieses Operettenprogramm der alten Zeit, 70er-Jahre, gezeigt hat, dass man, wenn man das nicht sehr vorsichtig betreibt, dass man sich ruckzuck in die Pleite manövrieren kann. Man hat halt ein Stofeuer und das wird feuerwerkartig verschossen und das war's.
Und das war ja dann 94, dass die Major League Soccer quasi wieder neu gegründet wurde.
Und die FIFA hat das auch ja sogar ein bisschen mit angeregt und mit gefördert, also zum Beispiel auch die Vergabe der Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in die USA war auch gedacht, um zu zeigen, okay, Fußball kann auch auf einem höheren Niveau in den USA funktionieren. Und hat aber die Liga aufgrund dieser Vorsicht eben all diese Verstrebungen eingezogen, die ich ja vorhin schon mal erwähnt habe, also diese Kopie dieser anderen Verhältnisse des Sports in den USA, statt sich also an anderen Modellen zu orientieren, sagen wir mal an dem, was in Europa stattfindet. Also ist eine Liga entstanden, die ist komplett dicht. Da kann man sich einkaufen, je nachdem, wie das aussieht. Aber man kann nichts eben nicht irgendwo unten in der untersten Liga anfangen und eine Mannschaft fördern und nach oben bringen und irgendwann in diese Liga bringen. Das heißt, diese Mechanismen, die auch dafür da sind, Sport qualitativ weiterzuentwickeln, zumindest im kommerziellen Bereich, die fehlen hier völlig. Und damit entsteht so eine Insel-Situation, die für vieles mitverantwortlich ist. Das ist so ein bisschen wie mir sahen mir, nur halt nicht auf dem hohen Niveau, auf dem das die Bäuer mit München vorexerzieren konnten. Und dazu kommt noch ein weiteres. Man hat, das war auch nicht blöd, man hat irgendwann, ich weiß nicht welches Jahr, einen Mann aus der NFL abgeworben, der ist Commissioner geworden, also der Geschäftsführer, da ist Don Garber, das ist ein Marketing-Fuchs. Man hat das klar gesehen, wir müssen gucken, dass wir uns hier nach außen unheimlich gut darstellen. Und so viele Kriterien von Entscheidungen, die da gefällt worden sind, haben halt damit zu tun, wie kann man dieses existierende Programm, wie kann man das besser verkaufen, wie kann man das ein Publikum schmackhaft machen. Und das ist eben jetzt, in der jetzigen Phase, wenn man auf die Zuschauerzahlen achtet, gelungen. Aber nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad. Also, Spieler-Nachwuchs in diese Liga reinzuholen, hauptsächlich inzwischen Lateinamerikaner, Mittelamerika, Südamerika, die amerikanischen Spieler werden also nicht hochgeholt. Leute wie Gressel aus Europa oder so kommen ja nun auch noch dazu. Nummer 2, der Trainer-Nachwuchs wird nicht wirklich herangeführt, so wie das in Deutschland mit diesen Akademie-Denken und der Ausbildung von Trainern existiert. Auch das fehlt hier. Und das Dritte ist, dass man sich auch wirklich nicht versteht, wie ein richtiger Teil dieser ganzen internationalen Fußballsituation, so dass man also solche Besonderheiten auslebt, wie wann ist Saison, also total kontraproduktiv, wann ein Play-Off-System, in dem eine mittelmäßige Mannschaft, wenn sie sich einigermaßen gut durchschlägt, Meister werden kann, all das ist irgendwie schräg. Und dazu kommt jetzt noch ein ganz entscheidender Faktor, dass dieses Produkt zwar im Stadion funktioniert, das ist ja auch logisch, ist ja auch attraktiv. Heißhockey zum Beispiel ist im Stadion oder in der Halle ein unglaublich faszinierender Sport, am Fernsehen eigentlich gar nicht so doll. Man denkt das immer, weil man kann den Puck besser verfolgen. Ist aber nicht so. Die Stimmung einer Heißhockey-Arena nimmt sich einfach mit. Fußball kann auch so sein. Aber der Wirtschaftsfaktor sind Fernsehrechte. Und die Fernsehrechtssituation ist für die MLS schlecht. Und das liegt auch an den Zuschauer-Einschaltquoten. Das Spiel um den Cup, das hat rund 4 Millionen Amerikaner ermittelt. Ich tippe mal, da sind Zahlen für den spanischsprachigen Fernsehteil nicht mit drin. Das ist wahnsinnig niedrig. Wir liegen bei einem durchschnittlichen NFL-Spiel beim Vierfachen oder so. Klingt schön, 4 Millionen, aber das ist ein Land von 330 Millionen Einwohnern. Das verschwindet wieder. Das heißt, man kann eben auch da in diesen Geldtopf nicht wirklich ran. Das ist schon besser geworden, aber es ist nicht genug. Da lernt man sich auch. Man kommt nicht wirklich vom Fleck. Jetzt habe ich den Faden verloren, du musst helfen.
Wir reiten gerade ein bisschen durch die Geschichte der Major League Soccer und stellen die Frage, du hast dann unter anderem den Marketing-Guru von der NFL mit reingebracht, warum steht die MLS da, wo sie jetzt ist? Dass sie sportlich nicht relevant ist, da hast du uns jetzt das Flaschenheizsystem und die fehlenden Träner beschrieben. Jetzt sind wir gerade ein bisschen bei der Finanzierung, das hattest du auch am Anfang gesagt, dass sich die MLS immer noch nicht trägt. Also sie wirft noch keine Gewinne ab für die Vereine, denen die Liga gehört und das liegt eben vor allem daran, dass es vor Ort gut funktioniert als Sport im Stadion, aber am Fernsehen nicht. Da sind wir jetzt hingekommen.
Genau. Und einer der Gründe, warum man wirtschaftlich nach wie vor so positiv wirkt, ist die Ausdehnung der Liga, also die Expansion oder wie wir hier Expansion sagen. Weil mit einer Expansion verbunden ist dieses System, dass jemand, der dann reingeholt wird oder rein darf, dass der eine sogenannte Expansion-Fee, also eine ziemlich hohe Gebühr bezahlen muss. Der kauft sich also ein, dieses Geld wird dann dazu verwendet, auf alle anderen, die schon drin sind in dieser Truppe, zu gleichen Teilen umzuverteilen. Das hilft also dazu, die Löcher zu stopfen, die bei den anderen existieren. Auf der anderen Seite ist das aber so etwas wie amerikanisches Roulette, also das heißt ja so, diese Spielform, wir nennen das hier Ponzi-Schem. Also solange es Leute gibt, die von außen reinkommen und reinzahlen, oder Pyramide nennt man das glaube ich.
Schneeballsystem kann man das nennen.
Schneeballsystem, genau. Solange es Leute von außen reinkommen und eben auch wachsende Beträge mit reinschießen, lassen sich einige Sachen verschmerzen und gleichzeitig führt aber eine Ausdehnung in der Horizontale, die führt nicht unbedingt zu Qualitätsgewinn, wenn es um das Kernangebot, nämlich den Fußball geht. Die würde ja durch eine vertikale Wettbewerbssituation viel markanter werden. Also oben, unten, Aufstieg, Abstieg zum Beispiel, können da den Druck erhöhen. In der Horizontalen kannst du den Druck nicht erhöhen. Du machst einfach nur die Suppe dünner, damit alle was davon haben. Das Kernproblem, wenn ich es versuche runterzubrechen, weil ich habe mich eben damit auch schon öfter beschäftigt und auch Leute gesprochen, die den Fußballverband, der dahinter steckt, hinter dem ganzen System, auch verklagt haben, um den an FIFA-Regeln zu erinnern. Was in diesem Land jetzt fehlt, nachdem Fußball kommerziell zumindest interessant genug aufgebaut worden ist, ist wirklich ein Unterbau, der zwei Dinge leistet. Der erstens das sportliche Förderband herstellt, das professioneller Mannschaftssport braucht. Der also wegkommt von der High School, der wegkommt vom College. Das ist notwendig.
Warum ist das College so schlecht, das habe ich noch nicht ganz verstanden. Weil sie sich nicht auf den Fußball konzentrieren können oder weil dort die Form der Ausbildung eine andere ist? Weil eigentlich sind das ja sehr professionelle Strukturen, in die man da als junger Spieler reinkommt.
Ja, aber nicht, was den Fußball angeht. Fußball ist an den Colleges wirklich keine sehr wichtige Sportart. Sie ist zwar total etabliert und sie haben vernünftige Trainings- und Spielmöglichkeiten. Sie haben auch den Stab, den man braucht, um das Ganze zu machen. Aber man spielt zum Beispiel nicht das ganze Jahr über Wettbewerbs-Fußball am College. Das sind nur ein paar Monate, in denen Mannschaften gegeneinander spielen. Und die Ausrichtung ist halt auch die, also wenn ich als junger Schüler sage, ich möchte jetzt eben an eine Uni gehen, das ja legitim ist, aber dann verlier ich ja das Profigeschäft aus dem Blick und falle damit auch aus für das Förderband Profi-Fußball. Die Fähigkeit, in einem so riesigen Land jetzt so einen Unterbau herzustellen, der bedeutet, ja, wir haben auch, sagen wir mal, Regionalliga oder Zweitliga-Qualität in mittelgroßen Städten oder vielleicht auch kleineren Städten, wie wir das jetzt in einem vergleichsweise kleinen Land wie Deutschland ja haben, wo die meisten Bundesliga-Clubs sind wirklich Großstadt-Clubs, mit ein paar Ausnahmen, aber in der Regel ist das so. Und darunter findet sich dann die zweite Gruppe wieder, das sind dann halt mittelgroße Städte oder so. Das heißt, ein Schema, das zeigt, wie kann die jeweilige wirtschaftliche Basis an einem Ort, auch so ein Unternehmen tragen helfen. Das ist das, was wir hier nicht haben und das auch von der Liga nicht gefördert wird. Die Liga möchte keinen Aufstieg und Abstieg, weil das schadet ja ihren wirtschaftlichen Interessen. Der Verband tut so, als ob das schlimm wäre, wenn man jetzt der Liga nach über 20 Jahren mal vor den Schienbeinen tritt oder so. Also von da kommt auch nichts, das ist das eine. Und das andere ist, dass wenn die Fans nicht wirklich anspruchsvoller werden, dann kommt eben da auch kein Druck. Und Anspruch kann man ja auf unterschiedliche Arten dokumentieren, indem man aus dem Stadion weg bleibt zum Beispiel. Oder indem man irgendwelche Blogs oder Podcasts macht, indem man sich äußert oder so.
Weil da gibt es ja sehr viele, aber die sind in der Tat sehr begeistert. Ich habe mal eine Weile mich so ein bisschen durchgehört durch die Fan-Podcasts, weil ich es beeindrucken fand, dass es da zu jedem Verein tatsächlich einen, gibt mindestens einen sogar. Die finden grundsätzlich immer alles ziemlich düfte. Aber ist das denn wirklich so schlimm, Jürgen? Also musst du es wirklich sagen?
Schlimm nicht, sondern nur, wenn es darum geht, korrigierend irgendwelche Wickelungen zu beeinflussen.
Du siehst so ein bisschen drohendes Unheil am Horizont.
Also wenn eine Blase irgendwann zusammenkracht, das hat man nicht unbedingt gleich zwei, drei Jahre vorher schon die Signale dafür. Das passiert dann, da wird irgendein Punkt erreicht, an dem es nicht mehr geht. Ich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass das hier der Fall sein wird. Ich glaube, wenn wir das alles noch abstrakt in den ganzen internationalen Fußball mit einbauen, dann werden wir erkennen, dass diese Konzentrationsprozesse, die wir jetzt erleben, also Stichwort Champions League und möglicherweise auch eine Gründung, wo sich Clubs abseilen und ihren eigenen Laden aufmachen und so, das ist ja alles nicht so unwahrscheinlich, auch wenn sich im Moment kaum jemand richtig ausmalen kann. Wir bekommen sicherlich eine Verschiebung bestimmter Schwerpunktentwicklung, die was damit zu tun haben, wie Geld und Geldflüsse kommerziellen Sportler einfließen. Die Existenz einer amerikanischen Liga, auf diesem gut gemanagten amerikanischen Liga, auf diesem Globus, die sehe ich überhaupt nicht gefährdet. Wer hier quasi den Monopolanspruch auf Fußball hat, der dürfte wirtschaftlich überleben können. Die entscheidende Frage ist immer auch, wenn ich aber jetzt mein Herz an sowas hängen möchte, kommt da auch guter Fußball bei raus. Ich gucke doch nicht Fußball, weil eine Million andere gucken. Ich gucke doch nicht Fußball, weil mich das beeindruckt, dass die da so viel Geld verdienen. Also super oder so. Ich möchte doch diese Tricks von Herrn Ibrahimovic sehen.
Und daran leidest du ein bisschen, Jürgen. Das hört man jetzt schon raus, dass die Qualität nicht so gut ist. Welche Rolle spielen denn da zum Beispiel so, Altern des Stars? Also die Liste ist ja mal wieder beeindruckend. Ibrahimovic, Carlos Vela, Bastian Schweinsteiger, Ashley Cole, Frank Lampert, Didier Drogba, Steven Gerard, Andrea Pirlo, Kaká, David Villier. Und damit habe ich nur ein paar genannt. Das ist ja durchaus eine Qualität und den guckt man ja gerne zu. Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht für das, was du jetzt gerade von der Liga fordest, dass sie sich quasi einer Leistungskultur unterwirft und damit auch ein bisschen besser wird in dem, was man da sportlich geboten bekommt?
Ja, also ich bin nicht sicher, ich kann dazu eine sehr knappe Antwort geben. Mich beschäftigt das aus dem Blickwinkel. Über 20 Jahre Liga, was ist wirklich sportlich dabei passiert? Ich erkenne nicht mehr als nur ein Trichter, in den irgendwelche Ingredienzen reingeflossen sind und da unten kommt ein ziemlich dünner Kaffee raus. Ich weiß, dass die sind keine doof Männer an der Arbeit, das ist nicht so, als ob die Leute hier zu blöd sind, so was zu machen. Es gibt einfach Kräfteverhältnisse, die dem ein bisschen im Wege stehen. Und für mich war der Moment, an dem ich begriffen habe, was ein sehr anerkannter und sehr erfolgreicher Geschäftsmann wie Michael Eisner, der hat den Disney-Konzern in einer bestimmten Phase gelenkt und ist somit verantwortlich für den Ausbau von Disney World und von bestimmten anderen Aspekten an Disney. Der ist dann irgendwann da geschasst worden, was schon mal passiert, dass also jemand rausfliegt. Aber der hat auch erfolgreich Filme produziert vorher und so. Also das ist ein wirklich scharf blickender Typ. Wo steckt er sein Geld rein, als er für sich und seinen Sohn, der also nun auch noch ein bisschen Starthilfe braucht im Geschäftsleben, als er überlegt, wo kann ich jetzt mich im Fußball engagieren. Der geht nach England, der geht nach Plymouth. Ich glaube Plymouth. Und kauft da irgendwie sich in der dritten Liga ein für 10 Millionen oder so. In einem missgemanagten Club. Aber mit der Idee, wenn ich hier alles richtig mache, komme ich mit meinem Investment vielleicht in die Premier League und komme an die großen Töpfe. Und da gibt es eben einen Qualitätsanspruch, in dem Fall von Seiten eines Geldgebers. Der geht weit über das, der erzeugt Effekte hoffentlich. Wenn ich das nicht habe, wenn ich diesen Druck nicht habe, komme ich doch nicht weiter. Das kommt doch nicht vom Himmel. Also die guten Trainerideen, die, was weiß ich, nehmen wir halt Guardiola oder so als Fall, wie sich da jemand vom Spieler zum Trainer entwickelt und dann so erfolgreich wird im Durchdenken des Spiels. Das geht doch nur da, wo der Anspruch da ist. Ich brauche Qualität, sonst würde der doch gleich wieder nach Hause geschickt, wenn der seine Männchen auf der Taktik-Tafel durch die Gegend schiebt. Was soll das oder so? Nein, weil es eben Qualität produziert und weil es sich beweist, wird es dann auch von anderen wahrgenommen und akzeptiert und vielleicht nachgeahmt oder sogar versuchen, Leute Antworten zu finden auf den Fußball.
Also Michael Eisner ist übrigens so Portsmouth. Da hat er sein Name.
Nicht Portsmouth.
Aber helfen denn jetzt dann dabei solche Spieler wie Schweinsteiger, Ibrahimovic und Co.? Man könnte ja von beiden Richtungen argumentieren. Einerseits könnte es sein, dass die Mitspieler sich von denen was abgucken, an denen ein bisschen hochziehen, sie eine gesamte Mannschaft ein bisschen auf ein anderes Level heben. Andererseits nehmen sie eventuell einem talentierten Spieler einen Platz weg und es sind halt so Showponies. Also wir alle warten halt dann, bis wir mal wieder irgendein Tor von Ibrahimovic sehen, was viral geht. Und wie er sich aber vorher die 70 Minuten über den Platz geschleppt hat, kriegt keiner mit und ist dann eigentlich auch egal, weil es geht halt nur um diesen einen Moment.
Aus dem kann man das schon alles ganz gut ablesen. Weil zunächst kommt da also unglaublicher Rummel zustande. Schweinsteiger hat auch aufgrund seiner Erfahrung in Ungarn mit Medien, kommt sympathisch rüber, ist bereit, mit jedem zu reden, zeigt also auch unterschiedlich, ich mag Chicago, was wahrscheinlich sogar der Fall ist. Mir gefällt das hier alles und so. Und er kann dann auch, wenn er auch nicht ganz fit, aber er kommt dann irgendwann ja mit rein in das Ganze, und er kann auch durch die Art und Weise, wie er Fußball spielt, eine durchschnittliche Mannschaft, die in der Phase gerade auch weit unten in der Tabelle hockt, nach vorne bringen. Was ja schon erstaunlich ist, weil ein Spieler alleine kann ja eigentlich nicht zehn andere komplett ummodellieren. Aber daran erkennt man teilweise auch, wie wenig es braucht, um eine Mannschaft auf dem vorherigen Niveau wie Chicago Fire nach vorne zu bringen. Aber wir reden ja hier nicht von einem Spieler mit unglaublich viel Ehrgeiz, der noch wirklich ganz viel sich und der Welt zu beweisen hat, sondern der wirklich dann sieht, ok, wenn ich richtig hart arbeite, das funktioniert. Aber ich kann ja nicht nur alleine arbeiten. Und dann guckt er sich um und sieht halt, was machen die anderen? Und das reicht nicht. Und die Veränderung, die er auch immer so ein bisschen angedeutet hat, die er gerne hätte und die natürlich auch da andere haben wollen, die leben dann wieder davon. Gibt es genug Geld, um noch andere teure Spieler zu holen? Gibt es genug Kreativität, um rauszukriegen, welche jungen Spieler haben denn wirklich was zu bieten und so? Ja, und jetzt gucken wir uns an, was ist aus Chicago Fire geworden? Ein Strohfeuer.
Vorletzter ihrer Division. Deutlichst die Playoffs verpasst.
Ja, und ich meine, es kann schon sein. Also ich habe jetzt hier noch eine Liste, die die Zeitschrift Forbes immer wieder macht, gerade mit allen möglichen Mannschaftssportarten. Die jüngste, die versuchen also den Marktwert und das Vermögen von Clubs zu bewerten. Atlanta United ist übrigens oben. Der Wert wird hier mit 330 Millionen Dollar angegeben. Danach Galaxy und Seattle Sounders, Chicago im Mittelfeld, Platz 13. Und damit das wichtigste Datum in der ganzen Situation dieser Liga. Das ist auch der sportliche Wert. Die haben sich eben nicht weiter im Vergleich zu den anderen Teams hocharbeiten können. Alles schön und gut. Also jede Idee ist, glaube ich, gut. Jede interessante neue Idee ist gut. Aber es liegt nicht an Schweinsteiger als Fußballer oder als Person. Oder wenn überhaupt nur, dass wir von einem Fußballer in einer späten Phase seiner Karriere reden, der also wirklich körperlich nicht mehr das bieten kann. Aber das kann man ihm nicht in die Schuhe schieben.
Ich glaube, vielleicht ist das wirklich ein ganz gutes Beispiel, was so etwas bewirken kann und zu was es aber nicht führt, dass nachhaltig ein Team deutlich besser wird. Jetzt musst du mir aber dann abschließend noch kurz erklären, warum investieren denn dann solche Unternehmen wie ein österreichischer Brausehersteller oder auch ein Fußball-Franchise wie Manchester City? Die haben ja investiert in eigene Vereine. Warum tun die das? Ist der Markt der USA einfach so interessant? Ist damit zu rechnen, dass irgendwann die Liga doch den Turnaround schafft und auch nachhaltige Gewinne hängen bleiben bei den Eigentümern von Vereinen?
Also Red Bulls, das ist ja schon lange her. Die haben sicherlich Amerika im Blick gehabt und dort eine Möglichkeit gesehen, sich relativ günstig einzukaufen. Und in der Zeit, als sie sich dann dazu, als sie das beschlossen haben, war auch schon das neue spezielle Fußballstadion dort auf dem Reißbrett. Das heißt, die wussten, sie kaufen jetzt nicht nur ein paar Spieler und einen Namen ein. Und dann ist ja dann auch den Klub ja auch umbenannt, der hieß ja vorher anders. Das kennt man ja, ein beliebtes Vorgehen. Und die nutzen auch am Stadtrand, das liegt ja in New Jersey, aber am Stadtrand von New York, ist das keine doofe Entscheidung. Man kann da auch andere Veranstaltungen laufen lassen, Freiluftkonzerte oder sonst was. Also es ist nicht nur auf Fußball fixiert. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass deren Kalkulation bezogen auf diesen Komplex Immobilie, auf jeden Fall, dass die sich quasi geistig abgesichert haben. Die haben nicht einfach nur spekuliert, oh lass uns mal einen Fußballklub haben. Und dann haben sie ja auch Wege gefunden, das mit den anderen Fußballambitionen in Europa ein bisschen zu verzahnen. Das lief am Anfang ein bisschen optimistischer ab. Inzwischen glaube ich gerade durch das, was sie dann später in Leipzig dann ja auf die Beine gestellt haben, hat sich das Ganze auch so ein bisschen wieder verschoben in der hausinternen Bewertung. Was ist ihnen jetzt wichtig? Ich glaube, bei den Red Bulls läuft das in New York nur noch ein bisschen mit. Während Leipzig ist eben wirklich das Prestigeprojekt. Und wenn wir sowas sehen wie New York City FC, das ist ja nun Manchester City und Geld aus dem Nahen Osten, da kann ich das noch nicht so richtig verstehen. Aber ich denke mal, dass da die Spekulation da ist. Okay, wenn der Preis stimmt, und die mussten ja nun also ein völlig neues Team auf die Beine stellen, wenn der Preis stimmt, dann kann man langfristig auch Geld wieder einspielen. Ich glaube, die haben einen langen Atem bei sowas. Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich alles, was dieser Tage im Nahen Osten so angezettelt wird, dieses ganze Soft-Power-Thema. Wie diese Staaten, so heißt es nun jetzt Saudi-Arabien mit Infantino oder Qatar oder so, wie die sich einbringen im Sport. Daran kann man ja erkennen, dass die oft auch einfach andere Überlegungen haben, als sich jetzt wirklich mit dem Sport genau zu, oder mit dem Fußball zu identifizieren. Sondern es geht auch darum, sich politisch, weltpolitisch so aufzustellen, dass man zeigt, wir sind von Bedeutung oder so. Eine völlig sportfremde Überlegung, aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch nachvollziehbar, wenn Geld da ist, dass man ja sowieso irgendwo ausgeben möchte.
Und es waren auch sogar nur 100 Millionen US-Dollar, die man 2013 zahlen musste. Das ist gar nicht so viel, wie ich erwartet hätte.
Du bist ja fit, ey, warum machst du das nicht alleine hier?
Weil ich ja nur dieses angelesene Wissen habe, Jürgen. Das bringt uns ja alles nicht weiter. Und das bringt ja auch nichts, wenn jemand versucht, eine sportliche Bewertung vorzunehmen, wenn er halt einmal ein paar Spiele gesehen hat. Da brauch ich dann schon so Leute wie dich, die mir das dann einbauen.
Aber es ist schön, ich mein, wir haben uns gegenseitig schon mal auf die Schenkel gehauen. Du bist ja immer super vorbereitet, das hilft dir auch, diesen Podcast in diese Qualitätsstufe zu bringen.
Jetzt nicht schon wieder.
Also wenn du verantwortlich wärst für Major League Soccer, dann wären die schon weiter.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, ich wäre der am schnellsten gefeuerte Kommissioner, weil ich dann tatsächlich nämlich sagen würde, sorry, aber in einer Blase leben funktioniert dann doch nicht, wenn ihr hier Sport machen wollt. Ihr könnt das gerne machen, aber dann behandeln wir es bitte wie die WWE und sagen von Anfang an, dass hier ist einfach nur ein künstliches Unterhaltungsprodukt oder wir machen sportlichen Wettkampf draus. Das wäre, glaube ich, die Entscheidung, die ich vorbeizustellen würde. Und beide Antworten sind legitim. Ich finde das auch so, wie das aufgezogen wird. Legitim. Andererseits ist es aber eben auch interessant, wie von Deutschland aus auf die Major League Soccer geguckt wird, nämlich ein bisschen anders, als wir es jetzt hier besprochen haben. Und auch rund um Julian Gressel und Kevin Kratz. Das sind ja schöne Geschichten. Und es ist ja auch toll, dass die in ihrer persönlichen Biografie diesen Schritt machen konnten, jetzt diesen Titel gewonnen haben. Wer weiß, vielleicht hole ich mir Julian Gressel auch mal für ein Tribüngespräch, wenn er da drauf Lust hat. Das ist alles sehr interessant. Aber man neigt dazu, dann eben diese Zahlen zu sehen mit den Dauerkarten und mit den Zuschauern. Und auch bei mir selbst merke ich es dann. Und dann vergisst man all das andere, all das Drumherum. Und auf einmal ist das dann eine ganz tolle Liga, die interessant ist. Und der Realitätsabgleich finde ich mit dir, der hat jetzt aber dann doch einige Lücken aufgezeigt, die es da gibt. Sportlicher Natur, aber auch finanzieller Natur, wie da die Struktur in der Liga ist. Also es ist eben noch kein rundes Projekt. Es ist kein Hochglanzprodukt, so wie es uns verkauft wird. Das ist nur die Marketing-Sicht, sondern es ist ein zusammengeschustertes Haus. Und da tropft es aber in manche Räume noch rein, muss man sagen. Andere sind schon ganz schön.
Also ich muss bei so was, während du das jetzt noch mal aufgeblättert hast, daran denken, wie sich manche Leute mit Popmusik zum Beispiel beschäftigen. Also wo Helene Fischer aufgrund der Tatsache, dass sie nun ganz viel Geld einspielt, da war neulich eine Statistik über Vergleiche aus der gesamten Welt und da war sie irgendwie ganz weit oben, ich glaube in den Top 10 oder so was. Oh, plötzlich die ganz große Überraschung und irgendwie angeblich eine Art von, ja wie soll man das nennen, so eine Unterfütterung einer Theorie, dass die auch, die muss auch gute Musik machen oder so. Ich mein, ich kann mit der nichts anfangen.
Du musst vorsichtig sein, was du sagst hier. In einem deutschsprachigen Podcast ist es sehr gefährlich, über Helene Fischer zu reden.
Nö, weil ich halte mich da auch sehr bedeckt. Ich sage nur, ich kann mit der nichts anfangen. Ich denke, was die handwerkliche Seite angeht, also in dem Fall ja eine Sängerin, eine Stimme, dass sie schon sehr gut weiß, was sie gut und was sie kann.
Die euphemischste Beleidigung, die man in einer künstlerischen Rezession haben kann. Handwerklich war die der Film gut gemacht.
Aber wenn es dann um das Produkt geht, also wir sprechen ja jetzt die ganze Zeit über Fußball, also was findet da auf dem Rasen statt und dann was findet bei Helene Fischer musikalisch statt, wenn das Ganze fertig ist. Dann muss ich halt sagen, gut, man muss jetzt nicht Äpfel und Birnen immer vergleichen. Wir hatten auch schon kreativere Phasen in der Popmusik und wieder weniger kreative Phasen. Aber diese Musik zeigt nirgendwo hin, außer dass sie halt die Leute zufrieden stellt, die da jetzt zum Beispiel die Platten kaufen oder die Streams sich anhören oder in die Konzerte gehen. Zu mehr zeigt das nicht. Das zeigt nicht nach vorne in die Zukunft. Das ist musikalisch nicht anregend, gar nichts. Dann kann man jetzt sagen, oh guck mal, ist das nicht toll, was da stattfindet? Und ich sage jetzt als alter Nölkopp, nee, das reicht mir nicht. Das gibt mir nichts. Und also bitte erzähl mir nicht, dass da jetzt die Tatsache, dass da jemand Millionen verdient, dass das irgendetwas bedeutet, außer das, was es ist, ja, ein wohlhabender Mensch. Und das sei diesem Menschen auch gegönnt. Ich misstgönne nicht jemandem, dass er Geld verdient. Ich finde nur, die Bewertung sollte von Leuten wie uns eben immer auch darauf hinweisen, naja, das ist nur ein Teil der Geschichte.
Absolut. So wie man ja auch sportliche Leistungen nicht nach dem Gehalt der jeweiligen Person bewerten soll, es ist nicht der eine Sportler automatisch der bessere Sportler, als der andere nur, weil er ein höheres Gehalt hat. Das ist ja dann wieder der Bogen zurück zum Sport. Jürgen, das war mal wieder sehr erkenntniserhellend, wie immer, wenn ich es schaffe, mich mit den USA zu verbinden, hier im Rasenfunk. Das bist ja dann immer du. Danke dir mal wieder für deine Zeit.
Wir sind glaube ich wieder etwas länger, als wir eigentlich wollten.
Ja, es ist aber noch gerade noch so im Rahmen, weißt du, ich alter Fuchs, habe dir schon eine Zielmarke genannt, die noch unter der Maximallänge lag.
Also wenn wir das noch mal irgendwann zu einem anderen Thema machen, dann darfst du mich auch gerne mal zwischendurch bremsen oder reingerätschen oder so.
Ja, aber will ich ja gar nicht. Ich mache das genau dann, wenn ich das möchte. Und ansonsten finde ich das wunderbar so. Und wie die Hörerinnen und Hörer es finden, das werden sie dir ja sowieso sagen, vermutlich wieder zu großen Teilen auf Twitter at American Arena ist da der Account eures Vertrauens dahintersteckt, nämlich Jürgen. Jürgen, danke dir, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst.
Danke dir, dass du mir die Möglichkeit gegeben hast, mich hier auszumelden. Und bis zum nächsten Mal, würde ich mal hoffen.
Ja, natürlich. Wir werden schon wieder irgendein Thema finden. Und das war dann der Kurzpassnummer 106, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hört ihn schnell fertig. Bisschen doof, das am Ende einer Sendung zu sagen. Denn schon morgen erscheint Kurzpassnummer 107. Und wenn alles gut geht, da können wir uns alle gegenseitig die Daumen drücken. Dann gibt es in der nächsten Woche auch noch Kurzpass 108 zusammen zu den drei Schlusskonferenzen, die noch in den nächsten Tagen kommen. Unglaublich, und dann ist erstmal Weihnachten. Macht es gut, bis bald, ciao.